let's recall what a zero is what's a
zero zero very closely related to
solutions and roots right it's the value
that if you have a polynomial like say
this right this polynomial can't be you
can't solve this because it's not equal
to anything it's not equal to a number
okay but I can still put numbers into it
for instance minus two which is going to
be minus that make the entire polynomial
0 okay and that's why they call it zeros
so if you have a polynomial degree and
how many zeros will that have now and is
right sort of okay kind of depends how
you count right I'm gonna keep this as
our answer but you need to put a
condition on it right namely which of
those ends sorry which is zeros are real
new numbers okay now the answer is none
of them may be real some of them may be
real or all of them may be real okay so
what does that mean let's just do some
simple examples okay we'll keep the
degree nice and low so did I get too
confused but taker is this x squared
plus five okay now if I want this thing
to be equal to zero find the values that
make it zero okay x squared plus five is
equal to zero
then I'm gonna get a negative value on
the right hand side and a square on the
left hand side right so what I've got
the eight plus or minus okay in this
case there are two zeros but neither of
them are real okay alternatively
obviously in normal cases you know both
might be real it on again
some okay let's raise the power little
bit so if we did say you know P of X is
equal to I don't know X cubed for
example for him plus X when you have a
cubic open for you okay because you've
got three zeroes right three zeroes you
may have all of them being real okay so
one two three okay but if I move it up
okay just shifted upwards like so okay I
don't only have one of them being real
well the other two are well they're
going to be complex I suppose like we
could we could make more not let's just
do it
I guess if I do P of X being equal to x
times x squared minus one so if I just
do this
okay so there's the first graph that I
did write three zeros they're all real
minus one zero one okay but if I move
this graph up far enough okay for
instance if I move it up a hundred units
okay I don't know what it will be but
when I solve this I'm gonna get this
scenario I've one route it'll be a
different one from before okay and then
because these are so high up only one
out of three will be real the other two
will be in complex okay so this is the
first property okay but there's a it's
sort of said more common ways namely
this is why I said it's it's three and a
half call this one okay if a polynomial
of degree n has n zeros right and some
are all maybe non somewhere or maybe
real okay we're usually actually are
just interested in the real ones okay so
the way this more commonly gets set and
it's in the program like this is that a
polynomial of degree n cannot have more
than zero okay so what this is opening
up the possibility is you might have
zero one or two sorry yeah thanks
okay so you might have some or none or
as many as you have off the degree okay
to grab that in graphing which is how I
kind of proved it right here's yet
another way of saying it which is that a
polynomial equation okay so if it's
actually equal to something of degree
it can't have now you gotta be careful
because sometimes the young sometimes
even the textbooks get this wrong but if
it's an equation it doesn't have zeros
it has solutions or if you're graphing
it has roots so these two really I hope
you conceived in the same statement just
in different context if you want to make
it even clearer you could add the word
expression in here to distinguish
between an equation specialist don't
have to have an equal sign